Film Courage: What was your feeling when you read the
script for Joker for the first time? Lawrence Sher, ASC [JOKER Movie Cinematographer]:  I
was just very excited when I read it it
was incredibly powerful even on the page
much like I think the final product I
was it was it you know scripts can go in
many ways and you read them particularly
when you're reading you know I used to
read scripts for a living like that's
when I first moved to Los Angeles my
first job was as a script reader so you
would spend you know weeks and weeks
reading dozens and hundreds of scripts
and so you you know screenplays aren't
necessarily always a correlation to the
movie that they'll become like there are
an amazing screenplays that are really
hard to translate on film and then there
are you know screenplays that are kind
of whatever that can translate quite
vividly and the medium is sort of not
necessarily correlates one to one this
screenplay and I've read obviously all
of Todd's stuff it was it was just a
beautiful page-turner in which every
single scene in every section of this
the story felt super vivid and I could
see instantly how we could translate
this screen in a successful way like it
wasn't one of those ones I just as used
as an example of where the correlation
wasn't necessarily gonna be one-to-one
it was you know it was it was exciting
to see something that was such a deep
dive into one human beings descent into
madness or perhaps his ascent into his
truest crazy self you know chaotic self
darkest self his rebirth of sorts so it
was it was a complex
screenplay and something I was super
excited to shoot for sure in terms of
the characters you know transformation
did any of the scenes concern you or did
you feel that actually you could go
darker that maybe they weren't enough to
really ramp up the emotion behind what
his life was like it's so funny because
it was so long ago you know two years or
so ago when I first read the screenplay
and over the course of making a movie
you dissect it
so much like you everything becomes
first your like breaking it down and
figuring out how but how are you gonna
schedule the movie and shoot it in this
parts and all these things that my first
read of the screenplay vs. like its
final product they're all know one thing
so it's an interesting question
perhaps it would I would almost need
more time to sort of go back into my
memory and think like was there
something I was scared about or was
there something certainly you know the
the couple very specific violent acts in
the movie I think you recognize okay the
movies gonna have these very specific
not a lot of them there's just like a
couple of specific points of violence
and you know the killing of Marie
Franklin which is at the end of the
movie spoiler I don't know where people
are a sumo slot of people have already
seen them will show you if they're
watching this but you recognize okay
that that's a powerful thing that that
this character is doing and how can we
align ourselves with Arthur Fleck
emotionally feel the humanity of him and
empathize with him as a human being and
yet still not rationalized his acts in
the movie and I think that was something
that I certainly was aware of certainly
for me that I felt like okay I think one
of our objectives in this movie is to
tell the story of a human being and how
a human being can take a certain path
and not necessarily you know absolve
those acts but recognize and understand
you know the causation of them and and
and that might be part of this the
telling of this story so you had a great
feeling about the script did you think
it was going to have the impact that
it's at now whether positive negative
box office results box office results I
thought it would be successful you know
probably you know in enough like I've
arranged in worldwide maybe 300 million
dollars that for the budget that we made
it on which was just under sixty million
dollars that
be okay like it wouldn't it would be
considered a hit
everyone would be fine you know Warner
Brothers would feel good about it I
thought it would be successful in that
range but the fact that it's become you
know made a billion dollars it broke the
r-rated box office record no there's no
way to predict that I certainly was
aware from the beginning that this was
gonna have more eyes on it like more
people were gonna be interested in this
movie and then perhaps anything Todd and
I had made before because the Joker lure
the DC Universe of that everything about
that character
partly because if Heath Ledger Jack
Nicholson Jared Leto all these sort of
versions of Joker I recognize that the
certain the fervent fan base was gonna
have a lot of interest and even the non
Ferdinand base which I would include
myself in that somebody who you know
like The Dark Knight series of the Nolan
series but not necessarily somebody who
like watches all the comic-book movies
would be interested in as well so we
went okay we know that the stakes are
high and it's not something where it can
just exist in this sort of niche little
place and you know film fans will find
it but we don't have to worry about the
the mass audience we recognize it yeah
this movie is gonna it's a it's it's
like if it falls and flat if it doesn't
work it's it's also gonna have a big
impact you know in the sense of it's not
going to be something that that is gonna
go unseen or unnoticed
so that was we were aware of that for
sure were you the only cinematographer
being considered for the job that only
Todd can is I mean I mean I'm yeah
exactly I've uh
I mean I've done the last six movies
this is our sixth film in 10 11 years
now I I mean he brought the script to me
quite early but only Todd knez okay was
he you know innocent the filmmaker the
director and DP relationship is such a
tight one it's such an important one we
work so closely together we argue
sometimes there's so many things that go
into that relationship even myself
having direct
I recognize how important that
relationship is and I never take for
granted the fact that I'm gonna get
another job with Todd simply because I
got the last four or five I just always
treat it like it's a new slate it's a
new movie he has a complete prerogative
and right to want to switch things up
choose somebody else all those things of
course I love working with them and I
would do it forever
but it's uh I also recognize that you
know it's uh it's it's it's and it's
like an at-will thing in which I'm
grateful every time I have the
opportunity to do a movie with him but I
don't know
I listen there was a lot of really good
TPS and I know Todd's fans of of many of
their work we talked about the other DPS
work so yeah I mean that's Todd I guess
when did you and Todd Phillips first
discuss Joker did he call you and say I
had this yeah he called me basically I'd
talked to me a little bit about the idea
like I think I think I figured out this
idea of like how we can make something
that could be really cool this character
study but we basically take a character
from the you know from DC Universe and
make something that just feels wholly
unique like sight not a comic book
movie really just like an old what could
have been made in the 70s but it just
happens to be you know you know a movie
and that's about somebody who ultimately
is part of that universe and I thought
that was amazing and that was before I
read the script that was probably I
don't know you know six months before I
read the script or something like that
and then finally once he sort of really
worked it out with Scott and got to a
place where it was like a draft in which
he wanted to show me that's when I first
read it but I'd known about the idea for
some months before that I was actually
working on Godzilla king of the monsters
in Atlanta and I was on my porch when
Todd it wasn't the call to say hey it
was more of like I sent you the script
have you read it yet let's talk about it
and so I had already read the script and
then
actually no maybe maybe I have anything
wrong maybe it was just a call that I
was sitting on my porch and he said I've
got the script I'll send it to you soon
but I'd like you to shoot it do you want
to shoot it and so it was that and I
just was sitting on the porch with my
wife and and our daughter I think at the
time who's like just been born in
Atlanta and and and I was like yeah man
I want to shoot this so I think it was
before I even read the script for sure
yeah yeah what do you talk about in your
first meeting with a director especially
a director that you know so well that
you've done many films with how is that
conversation different or the same as
maybe other conversations with other
directors when you first start a project
yeah it's interesting with Todd and I
our conversations were never like
long-winded five six hour of meetings
conversations are often like little
conversations or even sometimes just
like one or two ideas thrown out over
months and months and months so they're
never like really sometimes we'll do an
actual page turn and we'll do it in
small blocks where we actually turn
through the page and take notes on sort
of just ideas of like how we think we
should shoot this are there any specific
shots any special pieces of equipment is
this obscene that's hand held is it a
scene this long lens is it a scene that
has a lot of camera movement it's more
of just what's the emotion of the scene
and how do we translate that on screen
and so we'll do that probably later in
prep once um you know officially on the
job and we have some time to break off
and we'll do that you know as
successfully as we can to get all the
way through the script sometimes we
don't get all the way through the script
sometimes we just get through 30 or 40
pages but it starts to inform the bigger
picture of what the the movie's gonna be
early conversations are really pretty
short you know it's like I think our
first conversation on Joker was
literally about aspect ratio you know
about what format like what aspect ratio
we'd shoot it in and we both wanted to
shoot it in 185 which was great because
we were in agreement so that was pretty
straightforward it was like feels 185
and I was like yeah it feels 185 into
that conversation and then it was like
we're definitely
shoot film maybe we shoot large format
like 70 millimeter film you know we
we've loved those films it felt like
there was something about this movie in
in in you know in it's not Lawrence of
Arabia and that sort of 70 millimeter
way but more like perhaps the master in
the way that PT Anderson shot
large-format there in that it's a real
character study and that was a bit of a
two-hander between you know joaquin and
and what's-his-name great actor Philip
Seymour Hoffman right but nonetheless it
was an intimate story but really a deep
dive into the character and the minds of
these human beings and we thought oh
that would be an interesting way to
isolate this character in his
environment but allow us to sort of have
this almost like true three dimensional
quality where we could really draw the
audience into them by shooting large
format so we had that discussion early
and and then we just talked about how
just the vibe of it should feel handmade
like it doesn't want to feel even though
it's a studio movie it just wants to
feel very sort of constructed by human
beings and that doesn't want to feel too
polished and too clean and all these
things and and and then we would start
to say things like well you know it's a
character study in all those great
seventies movies which really were the
decade in which you would see those
character studies every weekend being
released in this theaters you know
whether it was you know obviously taxi
driver or something like that or King of
Comedy
of course those have some correlation
but also Serpico or Dog Day Afternoon or
straight time or any of these movies
that just felt singularly about somebody
Midnight Cowboy and and those vibes not
necessarily the look and feel the movies
per se because we weren't really
referencing them sometimes we'd
reference them and think though that's
that's gonna show us something about how
the movie should look and mostly we
would come away from like looking at a
scene or something out of those movies
and go it's not it's not really the look
of the movie like we would hope maybe oh
we can look at that that would be the
template and we could just copy that
template as to like color or contour
stur or the look and feel and it was
always like it's not really the movie so
a lot of it was the discovery of like
what the movie isn't to then figure out
like what the movie wants to be but
certainly tone wise and the fact that
those movies really were made by
filmmakers that felt unencumbered by the
studios and they were out there just
making these movies in an independent
way even though they were released by
the big studios that's I think the vibe
of what we talked about and so those
were the early conversations and then
you know you're having conversations
every day when you location scout right
every time you see a location even if
it's not the right one you discover
things about the scene you know you have
discussions about oh why isn't this not
the right one oh because I want him to
be able to travel from here to here and
so you're discovering things all the
time when you're in prep mostly in
location scouts even though location
scouts our arduous and I remember
Soderbergh when he claimed he was gonna
retire even though he like said I'm
retired and then made five movies that
year or something anyway he I think had
a quote or something where he's like I
just don't want to ever be I spend
another day in a scout fan cuz they're
just tiresome right to be in this van
traveling around going in and out of
like apartments and locations and just
they can be tiring and I understand what
filmmakers hate them but what's
interesting about them is how
informative they are to the look and
feel of the movie because you're got the
production designer you've got me you've
got Todd you've got the producer so
every day you're basically having those
discussions in ways that are sometimes
you know a sentence here sentence there
so that's the real prep of a movie as
opposed to like what you would imagine
or these like you know long eight-hour
days if I sitting and talking about
cerebrally about what the movie should
be there it's not really that at all and
also building that world the feel of the
sounds not just the music I'm talking
about like that they yelling out and in
this feeling of just total chaos when
when he would go out into the city and
how sort of contentious it was
I really I thought that was really well
done with the yelling like you'd hear
yeah even like all this I think the
sound design in the movie is
unbelievable and yeah it's like it's I
think the big thing that comes across
obviously in the script it was a big
part of the the story about about what
Todd was trying to do here was you know
how hard and and cold the city can be to
individuals right the city on mass is
this just like world of people sometimes
striking out violently against each
other but really you've got this like
sort of lonely man in the middle who at
his heart is actually quite gentle and
and all he's trying to do is sort of
continue to do his thing and he's really
just a an individual that's that's you
know that that I think it's a it's an
example of how society treats each other
and the effects that I can have
particularly when we either treat each
other without empathy and humanity or we
just look you know we have invisibility
you know we just like we just see past
them and walk past them and all those
sort of big ideas as to how society
treats each other and I think that was a
big part of it and and what better way
to sort of expose that but when Arthur
is in that world to show everyone around
him
you know as as as uncaring effectively
or just like and it's the word the words
more you know you know they that the
that the world the time in uncaring it's
like it said that they have no that
they're you're just invisible like on
the bus in the beginning yes the woman
sort of is saying you know please don't
bother my kid but everyone else on the
bus could care less you know nobody's
intervening nobody's sort of coming to
his defense nobody's really cares it's
just trying to do their thing so you
know I think that's part of it there was
also the feeling of disdain that people
had for him that you started and I don't
know if that was how the laughter
something that seems disarming then
became this tool of like or where people
looked at him with just this total
disdain like yeah I think it's like
disdain and and they're just
insignificant you know I think I think
we we can recognize in Arthur and his
struggle every day so many parts of
ourselves and you know it's the way you
look past a homeless person because
you'd rather not look at the person then
then confront the for the reality of
their situation or or or somebody who's
suffering from madness or psychosis like
we see them all the time in our in our
world we see them on the streets we walk
past them it's interesting like I had
somebody say the movie reminded them of
that Woody Allen movie with Kate
Blanchet that she won she was certainly
dominated though it was yeah blue
Jasmine right and I thought oh it was
really interesting because blue
Jasmine's like a origin story of a
person speaking crazy to themselves on a
bench right like that's ultimately she
ends up at the end of the movie it's
like blue Jasmine is just an origin
story of like how this woman got to be
in that bench and I thought oh yeah it's
actually a pretty similar analogy this
is an origin story of how this man
became the person he was and like all
the things that led to it and I thought
that was kind of a cool analogy and also
to there's a class issue because isn't
she in San Francisco and so having grown
up there I know especially in the 80s I
know you've talked about this in other
interviews but at that time a lot of
mentally ill people were on the streets
and yeah I would see that and that's why
I really picked up on the voices because
I would hear that a lot
as a child walking down the street in
San Francisco you would hear these this
yelling yeah and that movie dealt with
class in another way which was like she
came from money but she was now going to
a place of like losing it and what does
that feel like right like hey she
actually lived in both worlds and she
ends up just being that person that you
sort of you know walked right past and
don't think about and she's got a whole
story right and so this is this movie is
no different you know
it's it's a guy that you know it's it's
uh you wonder like in the backstory of
the people in the movie and I gave that
woman on the bus or the people on the
bus if this was like a real-life story
would go oh my god that guy the guy just
chopped Murray Franklin that's the same
guy on the bus like that you would even
do that thing where suddenly you know
you correlate one thing to another and
say like wow I barely even noticed him
right it's like that thing that you that
we do all the time with people that
strike out on society and suddenly
they're seen but you know previously
unseen so then the Santa Monica resident
I would agree so for them they thank you
you do that at Starbucks and you get a
look of like yeah I mean it's just
really interesting it's just I think
it's one of the powerful parts of this
movie that I think has helped it break
out and and frankly it's something that
I think I'm super proud of is besides
taking and making something that is holy
just a piece of entertainment that can
make money and you know all the things
that are the business of show business
has to do but as a piece of filmmaking
and storytelling that it can help to
shine a light on some of those issues
I've had people and q and A's and other
people who have said you know they
suffer from mental illness and it really
spoke to them and if it spoke very
powerfully to them and the fact that
they feel invisible and they felt feel
unseen and and all of these things and
and it's not that they feel that way and
feel like they want to strike out
against society the way Joker did it you
know it's that they just feel suddenly
like they understand like they feel just
a kinship with with the story that we
were telling and so it's it's that I
think is the most positive aspect of the
success of the movie is that it's
touched people you know peace you know
in ways that I think we would hope for
but but not necessarily expected how
much time did you have with Joaquin
Phoenix before principal photography
yeah it's a camera man you know
a cinematographer you you don't
necessarily spend that much time it
depends on the movie of course but it
depends also on the director and how
much rehearsing they do and you may have
if you have a director that does a ton
of her sing you may spend more time
prior to the movie starting working with
those actors and understanding a little
bit of them and they're certainly
filmmakers like Sydney the Matt and
other guys that like Hurst the whole
movie with all the actors and Todd's not
one of those guys
Joaquin I think is also not necessarily
one of those big rehearsal guys I think
he's he's a classic gamer in sports
metaphors
he just wants when it happens he wants
to be captured and he sort of wants it
to be when the movies happening for real
so my interactions with Joaquin were
very very small and nominal leading up
to the first day of shooting I'd see him
for makeup hair tests and certainly when
he was like in the office trying the
makeup on for a couple times we would
I'd come in I'd take some still pictures
of him gonna have a conversation of the
Todd about but it wasn't like we spent
much time together at all my first real
interactions with Akeem in a real sense
was basically day one of shooting
watching him perform like for the first
time first shot you know and and then
over the course of making the movie we
shot the movie in 58 days I then the
relationship really formed and you know
became a relationship by the end where
there was a lot more interaction and
conversations and certainly I think we
both understand to study each other a
little bit more he understood what I was
trying to do with the movie I certainly
of course had seen what he was doing
with the movie and so there was a lot
more interaction by the end and his
ability to make this character who in
the end is is powerful in a destructive
way but seems so fragile so I mean
there's so much so my arms around well
Arthur I felt so like he just okay great
well that's the whole beauty of the way
he sort of built the arc of the
character with him and Todd is it is
it's like it's I mean meek is one word
but it's not really that he's just a
he's just a gentle person like his place
and the move
in the in the early stages is one of you
know accommodating to some extent right
you know this there's this just like
there's a there's a sense of each sent
real human sends to him I mean he just
really created a very human character
that has all the frailties and and all
the things and and that makes even the
power of him wanting to be a comedian
which is such a high profile i I mean to
me comedians and obviously with Todd
having done so many comedies and I've
certainly shot a lot of comedies
comedians are the most fascinating
people and I feel like to stand up and
do comedy is the hardest thing in all of
the creative arts I really believe that
I think you are the most vulnerable of
naked because jokes are jokes right like
you go out to set out to do comedy it's
like what his mom says it's don't you
have to be funny to be a comedian it's
like it's cut and dry it's black and
white like you stand out in front in a
spotlight and you try to tell jokes if
people aren't laughing essentially
you're not a comedian and it's pretty
straight forward and there's not a lot
of argument you go out and make
something that's supposed to move people
generally speaking you don't know that
and and you're not knowing it instantly
you don't sense it from the audience
there it's a lot of internal stuff and I
respect so much anybody who tries
stand-up comedian stand-up comedy so to
me what a cool device to take this
person that's so small and like you say
you want to hug him because he's he's
obviously dresses up like a clown and he
has to perform so he has that part of
him but that dichotomy of character the
fact that he is this person that like
even when he's stretching his shoes and
you see the frailty of his body and how
skinny is and when even when when he
gets the gun from Randall he's even in
that moment he's just like I'm not
supposed to have a gun like it's all
very small and all very and I think
those elements of Arthur's character and
what what Keane did with them and Todd
of course is
to me is such a beautiful thing because
you see this massive dichotomy even
within the same human being and I think
that's what the movie is exploring right
it's exploring those two sides of all of
us you know that are battling constantly
right there's like a side that doesn't
want to be seen and there's a side that
wants to be seen there's a sign that
wants peace and harmony and there's a
side that wants chaos and madness right
and and I think that's really what the
movie deals with on a grand level and
and which direction do you decide to
take to take yourself you know and you
know I think in all of us we try to be
good but sometimes we're fighting our
inclinations to be rageful and angry and
all these things I don't think there's a
person among us who's not suffering from
from that that that part of ourselves
right that's what being human being is
and I think here you're seeing it
explored over the course of a two-hour
movie in a way that I think is pretty
pretty effective you could even take and
this is off going off on a tangent a
little bit but Andy Kaufman who had that
same thing and when he needed to be
larger than life he could be but then he
could be ladka you know that's right and
that was a good example of somebody who
almost seemed mad like when he decided
to be the other Andy Kaufman the one
that was like angry and it was off in
that exact thing right somebody gentle
matched with against anger right it's
like the aggressive Andy Kaufman that
would fight the wrestler and getting
punched by David you know like on the
David Letterman Show all those things it
like that's a complete opposite spectrum
of his personality but when he was in
that personality was in it so deeply
that he seemed almost mad right and
insane and so yeah I think it's a good
good as well since you had very few
meetings with Joaquin Phoenix correct
before shooting principal photography
how are you building trust with an actor
that's a really good question I think
you build it as you make the movie
honestly I think it's it's you're not
necessarily you know there's a certain
level of trust perhaps based on your
previous work and either they like the
work and they're not you know and I
frankly I don't even know I don't know
what Joaquin had seen of mine
outside of what he'd probably seen of
Todd's he certainly trusted Todd by
proxy maybe the things that Todd had
done successfully certainly over the
last five films that I had done with him
perhaps that gave Gabe walking in the
trust but I think it's no different than
Todd gaining trust with Joaquin I think
it happens every day in small ways right
and I think you're just constantly
looking to each other and and and and
he's looking for signs and I'm looking
for signs of trust and we're just trying
to find build that trust over time and
you know that's every movie and every
everybody means some and that's
sometimes the hardest part is when you
have an actor that comes in for just a
day or two and they've obviously have a
lot of experience or quite you know good
at what they do and in all those
situations or an actor that's just there
for one day you're trying to find a
place to build trust it's one of the fun
things about working on movies is
everything is kind of in hyperspeed you
know you work in an office perhaps you
get to know an office worker over the
course of six months a year and in many
many years but even in an office
situation day one for that person
they're all looking for signs
oh yes right I've worked in some offices
yeah that's just like they this is part
of human nature right we're just like
and I've always found like that that
part of filmmaking to be a subset that's
very interesting to me is the fact that
you take these disparate people you put
them together they all have special
skills they come together on a project
that the stakes are quite high sometimes
they're made for hundreds of millions of
dollars and and you all have to come
together and work together quite quickly
like you don't have months to get to
know each other you know you often have
just days to get in a situation in which
everyone kind of knows their role the
boundaries who's in charge it's it's a
very eternally find it fascinating just
the way movies work as a as a piece of
art and as a piece of commerce and and
I'm always interested in that and so you
learned some of those things but I think
for Joaquin you know it's also you know
he started watching some stuff played
back on on the monitor and he could
watch some stuff on dailies and I think
you
watching that I think he started to
understand what the movie was beyond his
work because you know as an actor he's
doing his thing but he also has to trust
that the editing is gonna work and the
cinematography is gonna work and and
everybody is coming together to like he
might think he's doing this amazing
thing but all that matters is also are
we capturing it you know and if he did
it and we didn't quite capture it well
then that's then we're not in sync so I
think it's like it's an important you
know aspect of filmmaking is that trust
thing and I think sometimes you don't
get it in this I think one of the things
I remember texting Todd very early on I
mean I want to say it was like day three
and it was just like a text of saying oh
man I think that our first three days
are going really well and it wasn't even
a kiss-up email I know Todd for the ages
and we we're far from ever kissing each
other up but I was actually genuinely
saying how impressed I was how how well
he works with actors because I've
obviously I've also done it myself in
that he's able to gain trust very
quickly and make them feel like he
they're in a really safe place and that
there's a really good give-and-take and
I just remember thinking oh this is the
movie is working well so far earlier
than I thought because a lot of movies
takes weeks simply because I could see
how much Joaquin already trusted Todd
and I thought that was that was a good
sign for sure yeah what's the most
emotion you felt filming
Joaquin's performance that's a really
good question I mean I felt that so many
different times I felt it
I think when he performs at the comedy
club is a pretty powerful one just
watching him be so exposed on stage
sort of failing and but just carrying on
and just they've something in his eyes
and that scene that has always gets me
the scene when he like is trying to get
the papers from the clerk Brian Tyree
Henry and and that little one-on-one
scene with the that's sort of in between
the clerk's the great that's in front of
separating them this this is just I love
that performance of that scene I find it
to be mesmerizing I'm always sort of
leaning forward when I watch that scene
with him I mean there's probably many
many I'm just trying to think of the
ones that pop to my head at first I
think that scene on the bus certainly
shooting that scene on the bus we shot
that scene it was day two or day three
maybe they too actually
so it was the second day of our shooting
was that scene on the bus with the kid
and the little boy and they like just
seen shooting his side of the action
right it's all cut up obviously like a
scene now but just shooting him perform
that scene that early in the shoot I
went oh my god this guy is something
else this guy is the best I've ever seen
and what he's doing already with this
performance and what he's doing to
create Arthur Fleck as a human being
who's suffering you know I thought it
was beautiful because in that one scene
he's doing everything right he's he
starts having just had gotten beaten up
by a bunch of kids in an alley so he's
coming into the scene still living in
that space looking out the window and
then he's not trying to connect and do
his thing which he's sort of conditioned
to do as a human being but also who he
really is which is to try to make some
little boy smile and then he sort of
reprimanded for it and then goes into
this coughing is this laughing fit which
I think always in bear
because it's on something he can't
control and then has to hand out this
card that describes it so in that one
scene it kind of like shows all the
facets of him as a human being and I've
always found that seem to be really
really powerful and also to the scene in
the bathroom where he confronts his yes
yeah yeah yeah yeah where he's really
truly you know just preaching and it's
like he's just trying to find a
connection you know and just trying to
sort of find that part of him that's
missing you know whether it's his father
or just another person to help you know
be there with him so he's not so lonely
in this world you know and the scenes
with his mother when they would watch
the game show or the talk show yeah
that's a lovely scene in the beginning
yeah even when he's washing her hair
it's like it's lovely it's like this is
at least two people have each other in
the world and I think that's what makes
the revelation of her and what she did
to him as a youngster and you know and
and allowing his abuse and some of those
things what makes it obviously so
powerful when it's revealed sure will
you ever laugh or cry while you're
filming know for sure I definitely
laughed
I mean I've laughed out loud obviously
Todd and I've made a bunch of movies in
which not many times but I've certainly
like laughed enough that it's like
gotten on the soundtrack and I'm like
God you know we obviously can't affect
this the take but but I've cried in
certainly operating the camera and
watching a scene before for sure for
sure I've done that in movies that I've
done I've been a part of yeah yeah
sometimes you're just incredibly moved
when you're watching something happen
for real sometimes you can separate
yourself and go into sort of work mode
in which you're you're thinking about
the next shot and Nick you're not as
present as you'd like to be but when you
are watching somebody work in a really
high level and they really are just
performing it you know in that way it
drags you right back into the present in
the best way possible and
you're compelled to just have nothing
else in your head except to watch that
person perform and then it can become
amazingly powerful and even if like I'm
not sure I cried and I certainly laughed
watching Joaquin because there was a lot
of physical humor in the movie that some
some of its not in the movie still but
just the way that he could do you know
whatever it was doing like you know
falling down or just his physicality and
you know the scene when he gets fired it
so it was a little bit of a longer scene
that is in the final cut of the movie
and when we shot that scene there was
like there were sections of that that I
just was I was heartbroken by because he
really wanted that job yeah you
recognized that losing that job was
really just it was very powerful to him
and and I remember when we shot that
scene feeling really moved for sure yeah
and I think that one was one of maybe
three were yeah I definition yeah he's
definitely again he's a human being in
spite of all that who he becomes and
this sort of like villain that the Joker
is supposed to be at you know at his
heart he's still just a man in the
filmmaking process for Joker was there
one scene maybe toward the beginning of
the principal photography where you said
this is going to be great and it just
energized you and it really kept you I'm
just like momentum yeah honestly it was
like the first shot every - the first
shot we did shooting the movie was him
at the social workers scene that is like
the second scene in the movie so when
he's laughing
that big laughing spell and then she
starts asking him about you know the job
and and he's asking like that whole
scene which is like seven or eight pages
or so material actually both social
worker scenes know when he comes back
the second time and says you never
listen to me or that we shot both those
scenes was like 10 pages of work in one
day not even a long day but that first
take of him performing
I went this is gonna be pretty great
like I was like this movie could be
divisive because it's darker than people
expected or maybe not as funny as they
would expect from Todd or I knew that
there would be some things in which you
go we we might not get all the you know
the Batman and the and the DC fans on
board but what we're gonna make is gonna
be something that we're gonna be really
proud of simply because I could see it
from that performance and then honestly
I was like I would go home and you know
excitedly show dailies to my wife and
just because I was so excited to show
her what we were doing so I was feeling
pretty strong and pretty like pretty
high high high about the movie all that
like from the beginning and then it was
really motivating because I recognize oh
wait okay so we can't let off the gas
ever like as opposed to like if you
start slowly and you start to get up to
speed and you're like by two weeks and
you're like oh wait now I understand the
movie and we're gonna start and then you
start like ramping and every day you're
like trying to make it better and better
here I was like oh shoot day 1 was great
day - it was great day 3 also great
scene alright now I was like every day
has to be this good and so then it was
just like a it was motivating to just
really keep hyper focused on making
something that I thought could be
certainly the best thing Todd and I had
done together and I want it to be the
best thing I had ever done I just did it
was like a definitely a thing where I
went I just want this to be the best
work I've ever done and so I just stayed
super focus every day to to not let off
the gas so I was feeling pretty hot you
know pretty positive about the movie
right away how much of the film is
improvisational I don't know how much
would be improvisational there's a lot
of improvisation as to like sort of the
way that we don't rehearse and we don't
just put down marks and we don't really
we just start shooting the scene and
sort of witnessing in real time and that
way it's very improvisational as far as
within the body of the scene not a ton
we did some scenes that were just ideas
for
you know that were not necessarily in
the script when we first started that
would just become sort of ideas that we
could do in terms of like him and the
apartment and things like that
but as far as and and and you know what
Keene was certainly fine to kind of go
off the script a little bit in terms of
just like for instance when he stood up
and he's playing with the gun and he's
like talking to himself about like oh
you're a really good dancer you know
that wasn't in the script that just was
happening in real time and you know may
have been discussions with Todd but for
me and my team it was just like this is
happening so let's just you know
photograph it but generally speaking
Todd's not one of those improv guys it
just goes all right now try this and
I'll try that it's if we're gonna change
the script he changes it with the actors
and and the writer and he kind of works
it out a new version of the scene and
then we'll just carry on from there and
shoot that version as opposed to sort of
changing it within the real
improvisation is more in this sort of
technique and and the fluidity in which
me and my camera operator would tell the
story as we would shoot the scenes and
the fact that we you know like I said we
wouldn't rehearse or put down marks and
those kind of things so we would just
make the movie a bit improvisationally
at times you know which was maybe half
the time was it in the script that at
times you weren't sure was this in
Arthur's mind or was it really happy I
think that's just part of the script
inherently right and part of the fact
that the Joker even in the lore of the
comic books is an unreliable narrator of
his own life so he will tell stories and
it's like was that the truthful story
yeah I think I'm not a big comic book
guy but I know from like reading stuff
and talking to people that he'll tell
back stories about himself in comic
books or graphic novels in which every
time he tells the story it's something
different I think to create this idea
that easy Oh is he ever being truthful
is any of it true he's none of it true
that kind of thing so I think inherent
to the script and certainly you're left
to sort of question and ask yourself is
that real was a mean obviously we do it
even in
within the body of the movie with the
Sophie character and that relationship
to allow us to sort of see a
manifestation of that idea in in a in a
relationship that he fantasizes about
and that yet we're seeing it in a way
that it looks like it's happening so I
think it's meant to allow you to have an
interpretation as the audience to decide
what's real and what's not
but it's certainly not something we
wanted to key in and tell the audience
precisely what was real and what wasn't
because I think we want the audience to
have their own interpretation we're in
the talk show like rehearsing for it and
and and and kind of being his best self
and then no spoilers but going there and
yeah yeah it's one of those things that
you know we again the taxi drivers often
use as a template for the movie and I
think obviously because it's a
disaffected guy who is doing a job and
he sort of strikes out against society a
little bit has some of those
correlations but you know even that
final final scene in taxi driver which
he picks up cybil shepherd and the taxi
cab is up for interpretation right and I
think when I watched it the first time I
questioned that interpretation but when
I watched it you know two weeks ago you
recognize how even potentially obvious
even the sort of stylistic aspects of
some of the camera work in that scene
could lead you to believe that like oh
did Travis Bickle go in that shootout
in the in the lair of the woman and
this whole PostScript of like him being
a hero and getting the letter from from
Jodie Foster's parents and is that all
just a dream or is that all just you
know a fantasy of like his afterlife or
whatever when I watched it when I was
you know in film school you know back in
college I never 90 necessarily go to
that interpretation but I recognize that
people do so I think similarly people
can do the same thing here if they
choose to
what was the most stressful scene and
filming Joker that's a great question
too
and how did you push through it I don't
think there was a thing you know the
scene when he finds the letter that
she's written to Thomas Wayne and then
he confronts her right he confronts her
and she runs into the bathroom and and
his mom and he's outside the bathroom
it's a very short scene in the movie
when we shot it is a bit longer it
started in the bedroom he kind of wakes
her up and then they go into the
bathroom and right now it's just kind of
like truncated in a good way I think but
that was a bit of a stressful scene
because initially it was written that he
was even gonna wait longer it was gonna
actually happen the next morning he was
gonna confront her and so we had planned
to do it as the script was and all these
things and I think just an example of
the ways in which we would often just
Zig away from our plan all the time that
was one of those examples and it came
very abruptly it was like we were gonna
shoot that the next day and it was he
finds the letter and I think Todd was
like let's just go right into it I was
there okay okay so it just became a
little bit of a stressful thing not
because of the change of plan but
because I think part of me really liked
the fact that he waited and there was
some elements of that that I was so
important so I think it just shook me up
a little bit and it's just I remember it
as a stressful shooting day you know and
and I'm glad the way it ends up in the
movie which is what it is but even the
result of the way we started in her in
the bedroom and I just remember it was
like a day in which you know Todd and I
were arguing a bit and I just it was a
memory of a stressful day for sure but
not necessarily because of the scene
itself you know even though it's a
emotional scene and he's confronting his
mom and all the stuff it was more of
just the way that sometimes scenes in a
movie or the the practical nature of
shooting the movie can become stressful
you know time constraints or or
differences of opinion in that kind of
way so that's I think a memory of some
of a day being stressful and where was
the apartment constructed at Steiner
studio in Brooklyn so the worry Franklin
set and the apartment were its
and and and and that apartment was burnt
Friedberg the designer did an amazing
job that apartment was pretty like it
was built you know a story up so so look
you know like I wasn't on an upper floor
but it it was all of his apartment right
which was at the bedroom in the bathroom
in that main living area with the
kitchen but that that long hallway is
also part of that as well that was also
built on stage and it's like it I don't
even know a hundred feet of hallway and
that actually leads right to Sophie's
room so that whole little quadrant of
like Sophie's the the long hallway and
Arthur's apartment was one big stage on
set so it was pretty pretty spectacular
because I think to get that long hallway
would that would feel like the tenement
that that he lives in you know just
involved a lot of space but that hallway
obviously plays a lot into the movie as
well as the elevator which was also
there as well and then downstairs the
elevator is part of the practical
location that we shot with Brooke in the
Bronx like when he's you know so those
tie in together through a movie magic
did you have to do any retakes on enough
like in LA or did you know and I
remember Todd at one point we did do
some reshoots so and that has become I
think more commonplace because Todd
doesn't like reissues I think resuits a
super common place in big-budget movies
often they'll do two or three big
reshoots you know in which they'll shoot
for weeks I've been apart a lot of them
a shot of many reshoots on the first
Godzilla I've done reshoots on big
movies you know so I recognize what that
is as far as modern filmmaking Todd in
our six movies together we've shot two
additional days and only one reshoot in
six movies okay yeah and the other
additional day was like a coda that we
added to the end of hangover 3 and so it
was like one of those things where it's
like oh we need to shoot one more thing
to add as opposed to even a reshoot but
I think with this and Todd so you know
even on war dogs and other movies I
think Todd's become more more to the to
the mindset of like rather than bring
people back which is so hard to get them
back in the frame of mind and all that
stuff
if I feel like there's something I want
to try differently
I'll reshoot it while we were shooting
so like when were dogs we shot one scene
two times in which we shot it he looked
at it anyway and I think there's
something we can do better
so we'd reshoot it so we did that a
couple times on on Joker also
recognizing and remember Todd said this
is like the the physical transformation
that Joaquin did losing all that weight
I don't know if he can do this again so
the idea that you would cut the movie
nine months later asked for Keane to re
transform his body and - that was just
untenable so I think Todd to his credit
really recognized that like if there's
anything we feel like even we might want
to reshoot we have to do it now we have
to do it within the body of like the
days we have so I think in the last
couple weeks of shooting we we allowed
for like a little bit of reshooting that
we would do not a lot but just a little
bit as well as like even the idea that
like if you had an idea that would come
up after you edited the movie like oh I
wish we had more scenes of him just by
himself exploring insomnia at night
which you might come up with once you
cut it then we started going well if
we're gonna do that let's do that now so
I think that's like the scene where he
crawls into the refrigerator it was an
example of that
whereas I wasn't in the script but it
was like through the exploration of
either now seeing cuts or just thinking
about the movie like Todd is as an
editor as well I think he recognized now
is our time to do it we can't wait until
you know after the movies cut
when was the first time you saw the film
in its entirety with a large audience
and what was your reaction to their
react yeah well I saw it early early on
in a cut and it gave Todd some notes and
and then I don't think I saw it for like
another two months well Todd took those
notes and all the rest of the notes from
all the times and just really fine-tuned
the movie and it was a screening for
Warner Brothers for like their worldwide
distribution I thought it was just a
screening he was gonna have for a couple
people Todd's like you want to see the
movie it's basically in its cut where I
think it's nearly nearly final cut if
not close and as I guess sure and then
when I went I went oh I didn't realize
it was like gonna be 400 people here and
like not a test audience but like
actually the Warner Brothers
distribution arm of like worldwide and I
was blown away I literally I when the
movie ended I went it's frickin
masterpiece like and I wasn't just me
like because I was a part of it in fact
I'm way harder on the movies I'm a part
of and can rarely separate myself in a
real objective way to like watch it and
get lost in it but I remember when he
does the stuff at the end and he's on
top of the police car and it just felt
so powerful and so operatic that I just
remember thinking god this is even
better than I thought it would be and I
thought it would be pretty good and I
think helping you know the audience
there and just really sensing the size
and the scope of the movie on that
screen and Warner Brothers said we work
show it's a really big screen so seeing
the power of that having just witnessed
it now on it editing monitors that were
quite small yeah I was I was actually
quite blown away and then I thought oh
jeez this thing could really be a hit
yeah were there reactions or not not
amazingly here's the thing the funny
part about that was I was like because I
turn to my wife who's there and I said
like halfway through or something like
is this working for you because unlike a
comedy where people are laughing you
really know like hangover I remember the
first time I start with an audience
you were like oh boy this thing is
actually could be a really big hit
because it was like raucous and you can
feel it in here
anyway I turned to her and I said it's
working for you she goes it's amazing
like loving and I go
alright good because I'm feeling the
same way you could sense the audience
you could feel their engagement you know
you know you know when audiences are
fidgeting there's a lot of tie like
things signs that you can tell with an
audience to see if it's working
particularly a movie that you're not
you're not looking for laughs what
you're looking for engagement sometimes
that's hard to see but when the movie
ended I was expecting because also it
was like Warner Brothers and their
distribution arm for there to be just
like spontaneous clapping like I was
even expecting like a standing ovation
and like there was none of that and I
went I was so weird and Todd goes no no
trust me I've watched this with just
smaller audiences too they never they're
usually just sit stuff and I went right
right right because then I remember they
took like a day in which I could finally
digest it and then started talking to
people I recognized that they the common
experience of the movie is that not one
of like clapping but one of like like
digesting what they've just seen and
being a little bit just frozen and then
a day later going oh my god that movie
was this or this movie really worked for
me and so we had like whole reception
afterwards with like distribution people
and from those people throughout the pit
throughout that afterwards people would
go oh my god this movie's amazing so I
went oh good it was working for everyone
but it didn't have that natural thing
that happens sometimes at the end of a
movie where there's like a sense of like
applause you know and all that kind of
stuff so it was an interesting
experience in that regard but clearly it
worked because you know they were really
high on it and all that stuff so yeah
great yeah you're right it does take
away I mean I was still thinking about
it I think two nights later yeah and
I've got letters friends and emails and
stuff they're there they say that they
go yeah I just needed a day or two but
now I recognize like it and then and
this is you don't get to a billion
dollars without people going more than
once generally speaking there have been
a lot of people I know you know and
people I don't think generally go see
movies more than
ones who have gone more than once - then
have it - like now know what the
experience was because I think it was it
was a different I think it was different
than anyone expected
certainly the trailer gave clues as to
the tone of the movie but I think I
think one of the surprises was what the
movie wasn't for the fans and what's
nice is that that was cool they were
cool with that you know sometimes I mean
I see even now with just this new Star
Wars movie fans are just they have such
a relationship with these movies and and
you know and so the people that were mad
at Ron Johnson are happy of what they
made changes in the new version but the
people that love the Rian Johnson
version are mad about what JJ Abrams is
like you can't please everyone so you
but you recognize it like they have a
relationship with these characters in
these movies so you have to be aware
that they're part of the experience and
so I think even if you want to stand
outside of that you still have to have
some interest into what their
experiences with the movie and I think I
think what's interesting is that the I
think a lot of the fans and in that
universe were happy that it was so
different and different unexpected
darker like you know they weren't as
upset over the things that we thought
they might be there's not enough action
it's not a comic book movie it doesn't
have this it doesn't have that all the
things that may be in the back of your
head you're going will the movie feel
too small well the movie not you know
service this sort of crowd that is it
has an expectation of what a joker movie
would be where all the things that I
think people really embraced and I think
it's great for the movie industry at
large that a movie that you know isn't
all those things can still make a
billion dollars on a lighter note I
think there's like an old Saturday Night
Live skit with William Shatner or he
like addresses yes proud of track yes
people it was a TV show you know but
that it encompasses this it meant so
much that's right that's right
we have relationships with movies are so
powerful and they're so good at moving
you emotionally and and when they're
done well they really you know you have
a connection with them and so and then
they become even more powerful as time
goes by and you know and so listen I I
think you you have to make movies aware
of your audience but not for your
audience right but I think you have to
also be aware of that day that they
exist in there they're there they're
part of the experience you know but you
hope that you don't necessarily cater
everything to them because as a
filmmaker your job is to tell this story
and and hope that if you tell it with
you know a very specific point of view
that it will connect with audiences at
large were you aware that so many people
that aren't necessarily into the comic
book genre would love the film I was my
hope because I came at it from a person
who is not a huge comic book fan so my
hope is like well my parents would see
it like they wouldn't necessarily go see
you know ant-man but you know because
they would think of as a comic book
movie but hopefully they would go see
this and enjoy it because they would it
wouldn't simply exist under that heading
you know and with exists on its own so
that was the hope and obviously you know
we can see they like what it is I
thought as we're making it for sure that
he goes we were making it I was saying I
was for sure going that audience it
doesn't like car movies will like this
but now we got to make sure we're not
you know that the audience that loves
them won't feel like what the hell is
this but but I sort of knew that what we
were making would service both because I
thought well first we're making a good
movie but I think in a weird way we're
making a movie that's very much like a
comic book movie in the truest sense in
the way that like kids when they're 10
years old would have this like very
personal experience with the actual
comic book right where it's just images
on a piece of paper with writing that
you
after them bring your own imagination
into the sort of deep emotion of it and
just like a novel would and I thought
like oh you know but it's a picture
novel right so literally it's like if we
can create these engaging images and we
and that in a way we were gonna create
something that maybe a very much a comic
book movie or certainly a movie that
feels like a graphic novel so you know
and and giving credit to your I think of
a sociology teacher you mentioned that
he said ya know these are a product of
our decade or you know the the been mine
butchering what he said no I wouldn't I
wasn't a film major in college I was an
economics major but I I got into film
late and then started taking some
classes because I was an economics major
I was always interested in sort of cause
and effect of things so he was a
sociology and a film professor he did
both and it was it was a basically that
the construct of the class was every
movie can be seen as a product of the
time in which it was made
Ryan we think in that class we literally
looked at the way three amigos
represented like iran-contra and like
that and it was like and so I'm always
fascinated literally to this day I've
never forgotten like what Richard
Slotkin who was the name of the
professor it said because now I always
look at the like even a year in movies
right and I look at them and I see what
are the trends here right and like what
are the trends that that we see in what
movies are being made you know I
remember I can't remember if who was
like the year of the revenant it was
like also the year of that all is lost
movie with Robert Redford and there was
like another movie and they're all
movies about like people lonely Pete
like alone trying to survive under great
odds like and it was like well what is
that saying about our society right now
or certainly like what does it say that
over the last 11 years right like Iron
Man one came out in 2008 let's say right
right and that kind of like restarted
the whole Marvel French
right and and this is just a theory but
like under the same principle that this
professor said is the GFC happened right
we now have like watched an entire
nation of like and world of bankers and
like irresponsible practices dismantle
the economy and nobody got taken a task
there was no justice at large there was
no justice nobody went into prison right
finds all this stuff and nobody
literally got pulled off in handcuffs
outside of maybe one guy and and I go so
we live in a world that has no justice
well what better place to show to like
have superhero movies become the most
you know popular genre of movie for the
last ten years because we live in a
world in which I think often we don't
see justice so what you see where do you
find justice you find justice and
superhero movies but you're not getting
justice from politicians you're not
getting justice from from you know
judges and lawyers you're getting
justice from like a literal superhero
they're the only ones who can give us
justice which isn't even realistic
because they don't exist so we've
created this thing in which we now want
to go see justice in movies because
we're not getting in a real life so then
there are microcosms that every year in
moviemaking so what is what our movies
trying to tell us about society and how
are they reflecting society and I've
always believed every movie is a
reflection of the directors personal
point of view and they're a reflection
of the society at large because I think
we all make movies in the context of
when they're made you know and so so I'm
always fascinated by that for sure what
are the best fights creative
collaborators should have also a really
good question they should always be
fighting about the movie right
never fight about the bull right
don't fight about win lunches and don't
fight about it like those are all
important things but they're not fights
that should be really happening you know
it's like don't fight like an egg you
know don't fight about bull just
fight about the creative things in the
movie right fight about
challenged each other to to not take the
easy way right there are a lot of this
the nature of filmmaking sometimes it's
just the path of least resistance the
past path with less friction people just
often want to check a box off so they
can complete it and move on to the next
task and I think I think it's always
important to to just be another voice in
the room that can challenge when when
maybe that that that we're taking the
route of Lisa of least resistance or
we're take we're taking the easy way out
instead of like continuing to push
ourselves to make the most uncompromised
version of the movie there are
compromises and everything so it's not
to say every single thing is is reason
to go to battle but I think you pick and
choose moments to just make sure that
like you know that that me and the
director and the actors and all the all
the departments are continuing to just
try to push ourselves to make the best
thing possible so as long as it's about
the movie I think the fights are
admirable and as long as you recognize
that it's a benevolent monarchy you know
or a benevolent dictatorship I should
say you really is that one person needs
to it's an essential part of the process
to be the final arbiter and that's the
director and that's pot that's super
necessary that director needs to at some
point draw the line and say this is the
way we're going and and discussions over
and you move on so as long as you don't
keep fighting past that never hold
grudges have a short memory right if you
don't get your way move on and and and
go go go into the next situation as if
nothing happened I think is is always
really really productive yeah I think
there's like this safety and it comes
back to trust where you know you can get
mad at someone and then the next day you
can see them and you can try to reset
that's right you hope that does exist
right yeah you hope that you don't get
to a point where you cross the line or
something has residual effect that's why
as long as it doesn't linger or lasts
then your
good place yeah just like any
relationship it's so different yeah
exactly it's a marriage of sorts you
know yeah and and also it's a family
it's the same way right and you want to
be able to fight with your family in
ways that you necessarily can't fight
with your co-workers or your or your
your your friends even in the way that
you know that the family is always still
going to be there right so and and and
unfortunately sometimes that means you
fight with your family worse than you
fight with your friends because you
don't create those boundaries but I
think it's very similar you know it's uh
you become super super close to the
people you work with and high stress
environments and all these other things
so you know it has all the fields as
they say you know in making a movie
filmmaking is not math it's Jeff yeah
yeah that's a Todd thing okay Todd says
I just love saying it I remember him
saying that like ages ago like I don't
know three movies ago but I just love it
it's like is such a great expression
because and we were talking about
somebody we had both worked with who was
super scientific about the way he would
add in a movie and the way he would
treat even jokes and it was like if the
joke works it would get made in the
movie but almost like it was just it was
it was where you were trying to turn
filmmaking into math that I think Todd
was like yeah it's like you can't one
plus one doesn't equal two in filmmaking
it's just something different you want
one plus one frankly to equal three are
you wanting to be greater than the sum
of its parts and there's an intangible
in there that is the the missing one
right and that intangible is like the
thing that is the jazz it's the it's the
being super present when you're making a
movie and watching everybody else move
and just which is what jazz is right
like when they start when jazz starts it
doesn't know where it's going doesn't
know where it ends and everybody has to
really be in sync and watch each other
and find their own place within the song
right so you you just like it's amazing
when you watch them they just
one guy takes over and suddenly he has
like a little solo on the drums and then
it switches back into like all four
pieces working together and then
suddenly now the trumpet as a solo and
all that ways in which everybody has a
place to shine but you're still working
as a group and and and the fact that you
don't necessarily know where it's going
I think it's just a cool way to think
about filmmaking is that you have this
structure which is your screenplay and
your plan but that you really should
just just sometimes just feel it out and
and and that way it'll allow you to
discover a new piece of music that you
didn't write before then right it's like
then it becomes something brand new and
that's the part of it that I really love
that expression
how did that happen on Joker well that
was sort of that thing of of not
rehearsing and not you know and just
just you know we started getting to the
place of this rolling the minute Martine
would walk into the room kind of thing
and so sometimes you just would roll
into it and you know you knew this
structure who's gonna be writing his
journal or he's gonna do this because
you still have to tell a story linearly
enough that you know you're tracking all
the things you want to track otherwise
the movie can feel too improvisational
right like and then it starts to feel a
bit you know meandering and lost and
some of those movies can work but I also
like you know when a movie has a certain
that you are following enough of a
structure that you're telling a very
specific story now within the body of
that specific structure you can be
improvisational and have some of that
jazz right which is just to allow the
actor enough freedom to be able to do
what they want to do and not bound it
into something where you know and that's
where the other actors that would have
to act against Joaquin would also have
to stay in that rhythm and that you know
and and you'd watch some actors who'd do
it beautifully I thought that Brian
Tyree Henry who did it immaculately well
because it's just an example of the
rhythm and the way in which were Keane
would drive a scene was always different
and just his pacing
even if the words were similar it was
just the way in which he would work that
that you know Brian had to stay in sync
with that and sometimes we would
intentionally that scene we
intentionally cross shot which is not
something most dps would go to normally
because it's somewhat compromising right
where you actually shoot both people at
the same time right normally you shoot
one at a time then the other person cut
them against each other simply because
you can just control the lighting and
that and they can compromise each other
if you do this but we shot that scene
purposely at the same time cross
shooting it with two cameras because
knowing that if Joaquin was gonna do
something that was a little off base we
wouldn't necessarily want to have to
replicate it on the other side so we
wanted to have the real time you know
reaction of who tried to do that as much
as possible
and so you know and a lot of them a lot
of the movie as you know one or two
people and seeing so sometimes that was
a little bit easier to do but if we
could shoot the two people we we did it
simply so that you know we didn't have
to feel like suddenly Joaquin had to
match something when he did it on the
other person's coverage so that was a
big part of like allowing that
improvisation to happened so we could do
very few takes but Joaquin had the
freedom to know that that it was being
captured and whatever he did with that
freedom would Joaquin ask questions
about the character or was it just it
was like he had already he knew Arthur
so well oh I mean there are so many
smoke breaks between Todd and Joaquin
there there are a lot of questions
that's its own movie right there yeah be
rollin oh I know I just like just the
the cigarette break the yeah I mean
that's the beauty of being a director
and and certainly is they have
conversations that are like wonderful
and myriad of stuff that I'm frankly not
necessarily always privy to so I think
they talked for hours I they talked
after hours there
a lot of questions and a lot of
conversations about who the character
was that's all in there it's not like
Joaquin had a very keen sense and then
that was it and we shot for 58 days that
they were adjusting it all the time it
so I think one of the things that Todd
does really well is there's also just
that he's he's super fluid as far as
recognizing the movie is being made
every day and you're discovering what
the movie is every day you have a plan
but you're really making the movie day
by day and and it's adjusting day by day
so you know you're making adjustments to
the character and you're discovering new
things about the character and and all
of these things and so that's happening
all the time and Todd is really good
about allowing that to happen because I
think it's a really good trait and a
director is to not be so single-minded
and focused on your plan that you lose
sight of potentially a better plan
what was Todd excited about the
filmmaking process for Joker right so
obviously I was on board like from the
moment one in terms of like really
feeling like we were moving in in the
right direction that we were making
something really great I think for sure
Todd knew that we were on the right
track but I think the process of making
Joker is tough on Todd you know and I
think where he experiences perhaps the
joy and the the thing that I was
experiencing as we were making it
I think Todd experiences when he's
editing it right and I think that's a
pretty common thing with directors
there's so many things you're thinking
of every step of the way when you're
directing that I think the process of
directing for some people can be less
joyful than others
you know Todd Solondz you know the guy
who did like happiness and stuff I
remember reading he like literally
hates making movies more than anything
he loves movies and making them at large
but the making like the day-by-day
shooting is and I may be quoting wrong
but at least I remembered hearing that I
recognize why Todd had probably falls
somewhere in the middle I don't think he
hates it but I think with Joker he
recognizes that every day there were a
lot of directions you could go and and I
think when you have to stick with one
you know you're it's fraught with a
certain level of you know just just you
you're so single-mindedly focused that i
think you you know Todd I think feels
that joy when he starts cutting whenever
I see Todd in the editing room I think
he he just feels like he's now
recognizing the fruits of the labor as
opposed to I'm sort of seeing some of
that in real time when we're making it
Todd I see that in the editing room so I
think Todd Todd what I think was
starting to realize oh good we made
something quite good once he started
putting it together
and recognizing like all the way the
pieces were coming together so and I can
only assume I'm not Todd but I can only
assume that also to the the little sort
of comment
area of the fans and the non-fans and
what are the critics and the think and
then the the the there's this you know
and so all of that gets heightened
especially well yeah yeah for Todd that
that kind of thing I feel like he at the
very least if it was in there it's only
internal to him and I can't speak to it
we never really talked about it outside
of the fact that we recognized that
there were a lot of eyes on us in the
same ways like there's so much paparazzi
and they're gonna be worried about it
well what is the Joker makeup look right
so it was like the first time in our
career together where I remember like
there had to be a conscious effort to
like get photos out of like what Joker's
makeup was gonna look like early enough
so that it got it didn't get out in
paparazzi and so you could actually like
give it to the fans so they can digest
it have their comments move on how much
of that affected Todd I can't speak to
for me I can see positive confidence
right away so it was good it was like
okay fair enough
and neither we don't do a deep dive to
try to like analyze it as far as like
and again I don't think Todd would make
an adjustment anyway I think he would
just say this is what it is if they like
it they like it if not then you know
they'll deal with it and hopefully the
movie will still convince them so I
don't know if that was a big part I
think it's just like trying to figure
out the character and make sure the
direction that's going and all those
things that are just the tricky part
about being a director whereas once he's
in the editing room it's really just him
and Jeff Groff the editor allowed to
kind of now in a more meditative way
take that material and start really
crafting the movie in a way that I think
allows Todd to sort of see it and see
how it's working you know as opposed to
me yeah just really you know I don't
know if I just it's like it's one of
those things also just I don't know cuz
I'm not Todd's head but you know I would
go home and we watch dailies which I
don't necessarily know if he would do
the same you know I would watch them
obviously because I was watching them to
see about adjustments but also you know
looking for things
we were doing right so we can continue
on that path yeah with the use of light
and color it was yeah just like also you
try to get a little objective when
you're in making the movie there's a lot
of stressors of the day time management
you know all the things they're trying
to do within a certain amount of time
and I think we watch dailies just to
have some objectivity to see is this
still the right direction is like that
lens choice the right direction how does
that translate when you now can watch it
with a little bit of distance you know
is Joker your best work yeah duckers is
the best thing I've done to date I think
I mean every movie I do I have certain
pride about it and you know some regrets
I I would go through a thing where I
would try to have the fewest number of
scenes that I thought I really didn't do
it best job I didn't like the choices I
made lighting is not as good as I should
I made a mistake those kind of things
sometimes I would just look to see if I
could get those number of scenes down to
you know five to four to three to one in
this I just think everyday I really sort
of pushed myself personally to try to do
a combination of make something that
it's really service the emotional
integrity of the story but also tried in
whatever way I could to be a bit more
artful than I perhaps had had chances to
be in other movies and so to really make
something that I felt like could service
the movie but also show a little bit
more of an artistic side of myself and
so in that regard I'm super proud of the
movie and the way it turned out because
it does feel like like a high watermark
for my own personal work and and
something where I now can to you know
every movie I ever do I literally try to
say this has to be the best thing I've
ever done every movie and and so I
always set out for that to be the goal
and certainly it was the you know one of
the last movies I've done so so I feel
like it's some extent I accomplished
that for myself and how does that feel
because I think you had said that there
was one year where you got one job and
you made like X amount of dollars and
I'm sure that was a very tough year and
now to have this be this monumental not
just the work but the Boks off yeah
results
yeah and that was like 20 years ago is
when I made this movie kissing Jessica
Stein and I think it was just there are
all kinds of watershed moments that you
have when you look back at a career and
and sometimes you obviously it's easier
to look back at them as opposed to when
they're happening that year was
monumental simply because
I was doing camera assisting and I was
sort of going back and forth between
shooting and assisting and I made a real
effort that year to stop doing any
assisting and really cut that tie off
and just hang in the wind with whatever
I could get my hands on and it was just
it was tough going cuz it's early in
your career and you you interview for a
lot of stuff but you don't necessarily
get it and kissing Jessica Stein was
near the end of the year and I remember
just thinking wow that was a tough year
it was like a year of struggle and yet
that movie then served to be at the time
was like the first movie of mine that
sort of went to festivals and made some
money and gave me a profile that allowed
me to get Garden State and Garden State
then allowed me to get you know Dukes of
Hazzard which allowed me to get studio
movies like Dan in real life or you know
or hangover and those kind of things so
each of those things ends up serving as
a stepping stone to the next thing so
you know I've had successes with movies
where like the hangover franchise
obviously gave a profile to me and and
Todd and allowed us to make more movies
and gave me some other opportunities but
I think between Godzilla this year and
Joker both being released in the in the
same year and being not necessarily
comedies or in that genre it's felt like
a really positive year because I've just
been able to sort of show a little
different gear of myself
photographically and and and just show
muscles that I think other people hadn't
si had an opportunity to see things that
I've always wanted to experience which
hopefully will lead to future projects
that will continue to show that side of
myself and allow me to do stuff that's
challenging but also a little bit
artistic as well I think I remember
sitting in the theater before some
arthouse film and Joker trailer came on
and it's not a film if I just heard it
on its own but when I saw the trailer
and saw with the with the light and the
colour and the music and everything I
was like okay this is one I definitely
want to see
and so it's interesting how that draws
in on comic book things right it's that
artistic yeah is that is that you know
in a weird way we made this 70s art
house movie I mean it's a really
challenging movie in the landscape of
ways to do just make in Malisse movies
these days you know in spite of the fact
that it obviously and it's helped by the
fact that it has the IP of Joker in DC
but on his face value it's like it's not
traditionally a movie that you would
think would be as successful as it would
be and I think that's obviously very
satisfying because we tried to make
something uncompromised and something
that we felt could be challenging and
and wholly original in our own way but
that can also you know go up in your
face and you make something that you
know doesn't doesn't do well and then
and then you know there's a whole nother
conversation about why I didn't do well
but but obviously we're really excited
about the fact that people have embraced
it what's the biggest lesson from Joker
that has not only changed you but you
can carry forward to if you were asked
to speak at a film school yeah yeah
that's yeah so what's the the biggest
lesson I took from joke or making Joker
that I would pass on to filmmakers I
think that there's two things I think
one to to really push yourself and take
chances and to just not take the
conservative route so I think one I
can't the movie very simple in a lot of
ways but every day and every every time
we set to do a scene I just made a
conscious effort to like not hold back
and to you know it's easy you take some
risks when you're young and then you get
opportunities in which the movies get
bigger and sometimes you're under time
constraints in which you have to go back
to like a thing you've done before in a
way that can be somewhat repetitive but
also conservative and I think if you can
find opportunities to to just be as
risky as you can
and to take chances I think the payoff
will be great and I think that's
something I take away for sure and also
when you you know when you think about
what yeah it also will the movie also
was an experience for me where I have a
lot of conversations between me Todd and
Joaquin about which direction we should
go sometimes it was like
photographically sometimes with the
character sometimes it was with the
story and because I've worked with Todd
six times I was involved in some of
those more intimately than perhaps some
cinematographers would be and I think
what I came across was was sometimes I
was right in my opinion and sometimes I
was wrong same thing with Todd and
Joaquin there were some times right and
so I think between the three of us
I recognize that all those conversations
and sometimes there were arguments and
sometimes they were heated I recognized
that like you're gonna be right
sometimes and you're not gonna be right
sometimes and so it's really important
to have a point of view and and fight
for that point of view but also
recognize that that you may not be right
and that the and that that that's always
an art and and so just don't be so
arrogant or self just like don't don't
don't feel that that if you're shot down
in your opinion or whatever direction
you think that suddenly it's not the
right thing for the movie because it may
well be and and you just can't see it
yet so I think it was like just a little
bit of an experience to recognize that
you know that there are a lot of
different choices you can make in a
movie and and the collaboration I think
is the most important thing and that
each opinion has its own as it has
really valid sort of pros and cons you
know what's been the most rewarding
thing to happen to you from making Joker
I mean I think I went to camera image
for the first time which is this film
festival in Poland that's up celebrate
cinematography and I'd known about it
for years within the cinematography
it's like the mecca where you go and
it's filled with just all the
cinematographers from across the world
that will bring their films of the year
it shows just about all the great films
of the year over the course of the sort
of the week-long festival and I was
lucky enough to be in competition in the
film in the in this festival with like
13 other films that were vying for like
these frogs like you know the golden
frog which is like the best film of the
year from a cinematography standpoint so
experiencing that festival which was
such a joyous experience of being with
other cinematographers and filmmakers
and film students and camera people from
across the world and just celebrating
film and also celebrating more
specifically cinematography that was one
of my finest experiences I've had in
many many years which was amazing and
and being able to do some seminars and
be on the jury and talked to so many
young filmmakers who just are excited
about making movies was awesome and that
the fact that Joker was in competition
allowed me to go but also you know and
then and then and and so that experience
was wonderful and then Joker ended up
winning the Golden Frog so so that was
icing on the cake so that was amazing
that wouldn't have happened without
Joker for sure yeah and then you know
yeah so just feeling like I'm in my
element here I'm just like I mean I
always wanted to go to camera Maj so it
was more a function if I would have
probably gone I'll you know anyway
without the film but obviously having
the film there and being able to show it
to all my peers and and have it play
there and experience that that was that
was certainly wonderful and came because
of Joker's so that was pretty great yeah
and I wasn't because I was working and
shooting a movie I wasn't able to go to
Venice which I would have loved to have
gone I remember going to Venice as just
a tourist and staying in the hotel where
they have the Venice Film Festival and
being like god this feels like old
Hollywood like how great would it be to
have a film
at the Venice Film Festival I remember
after that vacation which was before we
made Joker it was right before we made
Joker that vacation where I went to
Italy with my son I remember saying to
Todd man how cool would it be if Joker
could play at the Venice Film Festival
and then it went and played with Memphis
and won the Golden Lion which was
bonkers so for Todd it was like not only
did it get to play there he got this
same experience of like winning the top
prize there and so that must have been
amazing for him so so you know not
having that experience the camera image
was like my version of that yeah